Anxiety disorders are closely tied to panic disorders. A panic disorder is
defined by frequent panic attacks and pervasive and persistent fear worry and
embarrassment about having panic attacks in the future. So the center of panics
disorders is the panic attack. Panic attacks involves sudden changes in body
and mind. Panic attacks are characterized by an overwhelming sense of impending
doom, heart palpitations, trembling, sweating, shortness of breath, dizziness,
intense dread, nausea and even a fear of death. These attacks are associated
with perceptions of threat. It can occur for a number of reasons. For example,
fear of danger, inability to escape, fear of embarrassment or fear of a
specific category of objects. Panic attacks usually last for about ten minutes.
But sometimes can come and go over a period of an hour or more. Due to their
physiological effects, people undergoing a panic attack may believe they're
having a heart attack or going crazy. As you can imagine, this can be extremely
frightening. If a person has a panic disorder, there is a preoccupation of
being worried about having a panic attack. And this puts a person in an anxious
mood, which increases the likelihood of more worrisome thoughts which can
trigger another panic attack. To receive a diagnosis of panic disorder, a panic
attack must be followed by at least a month of persistent worry over future
attacks, along with the development of potentially maladaptive behaviors to
avoid attacks. Such as avoidance of putting oneself in an unfamiliar situation.
People with this disorder may tend to disengage themselves from activities that
they once enjoyed for fear of experiencing panic attacks. For example, some
people go to the extreme of avoiding being out in public. And that brings us to
our next disorder. Agoraphobia. Agoraphobia is a specific phobia involving a
fear of venturing into public places. Now, it's not that people are actually
afraid of the public places. But rather, they're afraid of having a panic
attack while they're out. In severe cases, people are unable to leave their
homes. Sometimes for years on end. About 22% of Americans have reported having
at least one panic attack. But this does not result in diagnosis of a panic
disorder. In addition to having the panic attack, a person also has to
experience the dread and anxiety about having another Panic attack. For
example, I once had a panic attack. It was terrifying, and all of those
symptoms felt very real. It was when I was on an airplane one time. But I
haven't ever had a panic attack since that one flight, so just because I had
the one panic attack when I was flying, doesn't mean I have a panic disorder.
And on top of that it doesn't mean I'm even scared of flying anymore. With all
the diagnostic criteria, it turns out that approximately 3.5% of people will
have a diagnosable panic disorder sometime in their life. And 43% of those
people who do have a panic disorder will develop agoraphobia. Now, let's go to
Greg with a little more about phobias.